there may be life in the prospect of a
brexit deal yet
EU and UK negotiators will have to work
flat out between now and next week's
Brussels summit if they're to come up
with a framework agreement we had a
constructive meeting with devar clay the
British team and now I am going to
debrief the 27 ambassadors and the
brexit steering group of the farm but
has already said that the brexit is like
climbing a mountain
we need the vigilance determination and
patience EU Council President Donald
Tusk had warned he was ready to declare
the talks dead on Friday instead
technical talks are taking place in
Brussels as we speak of course there's
no guarantee of success and the time is
practically up but even the slightest
chance must feel but what's all this
renewed optimism based on in truth no
one quite knows beyond comments made by
UK Prime Minister Boris Johnson and the
Irish tea shock Leo vodka on Thursday
that they saw a narrow path to a deal
the pair had met for three hours in the
northwest of England much of that time
in private concessions were made but
they wouldn't say by whom and all else
is secret well I can certainly tell you
that under no circumstances will we see
anything that damages the ability of the
whole of the United Kingdom to take full
advantage of a brexit what Johnson is
alluding to there is the whole of the
United Kingdom including Northern
Ireland leaving the EU customs union
it's the Holy Grail among breaks its
supporters allowing the UK to pursue
independent trade deals but Prime
Minister Johnson's previous proposals
went down in flames when the EU rejected
among other things the idea of customs
checks on the island of
and whatever has been concocted as an
alternative has now entered what the EU
calls the negotiating tunnel with just
the faintest glimmer of light at the
other end
Jonah hole al-jazeera London